[Music]
so what brings you to tacoma
vacation from the kids oh no kids that
ship has sailed it's our 10-year
anniversary safety
as they will get you everything you need
oh even heroin sorry just joking that's
a bad joke i'm starting to forget who i
am no work
no stress no regrets
when would you see where this leads us
[Music]
this phone belongs to a kid who went
missing down here 15 years ago
and belonged to sam walford
sam and his mom and his dad and his
girlfriend arrived at this resort on
christmas night
but then the next morning he's gone
later on this other guest from the
resort was also reported missing
do you want to get out of here
my daughter wanted to spend christmas
here
but she didn't want to spend it with me
we found a boy skateboard
you ever feel like something from the
past is missing from your future
i'm gonna get some answers
hey come back here
but what if there aren't any answers
well there have to be
because otherwise what is the [ __ ]
point
you